jihadi witnesses I know it last Saturday
too if I end up on CNN can I help you we
want to tell you the news your good news
bit no bad news terrible news it's so
bad I can't say I'm not hearing have you
thought of giving the life to our lawn
waving this holy jihad I'll be honest I
hear jihad I think it's a bad I know I
know there are so many misconceptions
about jihad I'm here to clear that up a
little bit it's not that I was about
waging a holy war against all
non-muslims involving subjugation
conversion or ultimately execution
that's it's exactly what you think you
know I just don't think it's for me
people think of that he had they think
of the big of the Demeter they don't
really know of all the perks I'm still
listening okay let's say you are married
and you are the wife who's maybe abusive
or maybe she's inconsiderate God maybe
you just got tired of it not only can
you hit her but if you want to divorce
her you just need to say divorce divorce
three times with any mom oh gosh - bus
tours scot-free
she's completely sound intriguing I'm
not really married I get okay you're a
man who likes to play the field I like
that I like that about you know let's
say scenario B you're not want to get
married do you want to use your options
right well have you heard of ten already
managed okay this is what you can
fornicate without the gift he loves God
no I am creepy quirks
you know it's not really my thing I mean
why I don't think this sounds like over
women but your power over everyone who's
not Muslim do you mean okay let's just
say you join us in our jihad okay and
allows will be done on earth as
predicted in the Quran by our police
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
you're no longer subjected to the deme -
that whole - the curfews or the general
just the crappy treatment of all
non-muslims give full disclosure
pretty sounded a bit like generous whoa
whoa wait a minute we don't want to have
to come yeah that is offensive and I
like you okay I want to make a deal with
you
listen it just comes off like one things
right listen I get where you're coming
from okay
but I just don't think it's for us wait
there I think maybe we can still work
something out you wait
[Music]
be sure to subscribe by clicking my face
here on YouTube clicking the video next
to me or subscribe on iTunes SoundCloud
or loud or with Crider com it's all free
and I'm sure many of you will still find
a reason to [ __ ] about it